hello reject nation it's greg alba here
and i'm john i found out the other day
from john that film school rejects calls
their people the reject nation to or at
least their twitter account
yeah well it's a war now between to
reject nations when really we should all
just be united no that's not the way the
reject nation works
we're gonna watch today from mighty
raccoon an awesome animated channel
these five ways to stop thanos today
we're gonna give a page from the day
shout out to Derek Mitchell how are you
doing my friend last time we talked you
said that you were transitioning out of
uber or lyft whichever one it is you do
and trying to get an IT job at a
corporate gig I hope you do land that
job Derek Mitchell because working for
corporate is the American dream mmm
you will find fulfillment and pure
happiness enjoy working for the man
pension health insurance 401k sitting at
an office desk looking at a computer all
day much similar to working at home and
running a YouTube channel it's gonna be
great buddy I hope you find pure joy in
the man red stapler boilers I haven't
seen we're gonna stop that it was today
people yeah
give me the time stone
[Music]
blow up oh yeah oh yeah
[Music]
yes we did
[Music]
[Music]
ha
[Laughter]
[Music]
wordless waves you should have gone for
the head
[Music]
the cha take it mean take it to me
[Music]
tell me you didn't kill her you're so
close to stopping him don't do anything
stupid
[Music]
let's get this off
[Music]
[Applause]
shot him like even even that blow his
head off but just blast him away because
he has those blaster abilities just push
someone but not hurt like kill them yeah
forced punch him in the knees like if
anything you don't have to kill him
though yes I think the only thing this
video lacked for me was to see John wick
actually go after that Doctor Strange
one though that first one is actually I
thought was really clever it was early
could do that because they do that they
do anything in the movie with the giant
guy brought her to my wedding this is so
funny because except for the like the
John wick one but but all of them are
fathomable they're always where they
could have worked the comic timing on
the after the beats of defeating him I
love the way they like scripted it and
beated it out because the pauses after
the defeats are really funny yeah like
Oh always just bummed out I mean the
ant-man one has been one that I've heard
many people talk about so we all saw
that coming like Oh a man is gonna go
when there chouriço this is got a
graphic watching it hear that yeah I
can't personally I can't wait for the
day where the MCU finally starts doing
stuff like that all rated movies that's
how easy it takes ant-man just kills
every movie every all that's pretty soon
all the criminals are walking around
with earplugs yeah or even the Captain
America one where he's yeah in the movie
his fist is not close he's holding it
because like when everyone's trying to
do is prevent him from closing his fist
I guess he could have taken it off he
had enough power to hold him back now
it's probably smart enough to know not
to close his hand yeah easy for his
fingers to come but that was a really
funny beat though when he took it off it
caps like I think the doctor strange one
is the most inventive one I think the
most obvious one would have been Iron
Man blasting star-lord the third time I
watched it that's especially what I
thought he could have just pushed him a
little bit away we could have won Spidey
could a web blast
like get him away this is a really funny
video man this is like this is a really
funny video III this video made me
really happy yeah well and there's
something I find very charming about the
animation style here too like it's not
necessarily the most state of the art
but it's perfect for what this is and it
helps actually accentuate the comedy for
me all the superheroes without their
mask on look like Chris Redfield yeah
you know you get where they're going I
think they all pretty much resemble
except for maybe star-lord yeah all
right well mighty raccoon if you guys
haven't subscribed to this channel make
sure to do it right away you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification Bell check us out on
patreon full-length TV show reactions
weekly Q&A is music video coverage would
love to have you become a patreon object
today people please